Hallo, mein Name ist Mokrokarakus. Ich bin auch diese Station als Astetik.
So erst würde mit Ihnen das Eskieschiebre führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Ja, okay. So erst stelle ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Anschließend besprechen wir Ihren aktuellen Beschwörden.
Wie fahren Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jürgen Winter.
Herr Winter, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, erst den Nachnamen. Das ist Winter wie Sommer. W-I-N-T-E-R.
Ja.
Und der Vorname ist Jürgen-J-Ü-R-G-E-N.
Ja, N. Danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt. Bin geboren am 2. 1. 84.
84? Ach Sie. Danke schön für die Informationen.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 84 und wie total so 65, 64, ja, 94, 95 Kilo.
94?
Mhm.
Okay. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was für Beschwörden haben Sie?
Ja, also mit einmal hat es vor zwei Stunden angefangen,
dass ich so ganz starke Schmerzen hier so oben in der Brust hatte.
Und das Stach so ganz doll. Und ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass alles ganz eng ist, dass ich gar nicht gut Luft bekommen kann.
Und also gerade beim Einatmen war das ganz schmerzhaft.
Und das zog dann auch so in den linken Armen rein.
Und da habe ich richtig Panik bekommen.
Und also ganz am Anfang waren die Schmerzen richtig heftig.
Jetzt ist es also deutlich weniger.
Aber ja, also mir ist, ich habe jetzt wirklich Angst gehabt.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich, dass mir ein bisschen schlecht ist
und dass das Herz ganz schnell klopft und auch so,
dass ich mir einmal ganz schwitzig bin.
Also es geht mir, ging mir ganz schön.
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser.
Aber also die Schmerzen waren wirklich krass.
Und jetzt geht es ein klein wenig besser.
Aber ich habe immer noch so diese Angst so.
Angst.
Ich verstehe Ihren Hauptjahr Beschwörden.
Sie haben seit zwei Stunden Brustschmerzen und Angergefühl.
Ja.
Sie haben Angst und die Schmerzen strahlen in der linken Seite.
Richtig?
Im linken Armen, ja.
Ja, linken Armen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja.
Okay.
Also ich habe mich noch nicht übergeben,
aber ich fühle mich die ganze Zeit so,
als ob das jetzt gleich passieren könnte.
Ja.
Okay.
Danke schön Informationen.
Das kann Notfallstation sein.
Ich würde jetzt dieses Aufnahmegespräch unterbrechen.
Ich werde Sie an den Monitor einschließen und Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Sauerstoffsetigung, Kulstatus, Herz-, Atmung-Kurrikan,
Bluthochdruck.
Und gleichzeitig würde ich Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben.
Ja, das wäre gut.
Ja, da fühle ich mich glaube ich auch wieder sicherer.
Ja.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie gegen irgendwelche Mediamente?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich irgendwie, also bisher habe ich immer alles vertragen.
Ja, alles vertragen.
Mhm.
Gut, jetzt werde ich Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Ja, jetzt also unterbrechen.
Genau.
Ja, gleichzeitig bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen und danach könnten wir weiter machen.
Gut.
Sehr gut.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Also jetzt, Zeitraffer, ja, wir haben die Untersuchung gemacht
und jetzt geht das Gespräch weiter.
Ja, ich lebe noch, also.
Ja.
Wie geht es Ihnen jetzt?
Ja, ein klein bisschen besser, ja.
Ja, okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Brustschmerzen, die seit 2 Stunden bestärken.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche oder bestimmte Auslöser bemerkt?
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Also ich habe das schon im Laufe des letzten Jahres immer mal gehabt.
Da war das aber so.
Macht der Messen oder Treppensteigen?
Nein, da war das so, dass ich mich angestrengt hatte, ja.
Also einmal war das, als ich auf dem Termin schnell der Treppe hoch gelaufen bin
und ich hatte es eilig und der Aufzuch hat nicht funktioniert.
Und ja, da kam ich oben an und hatte so das Gefühl, oh, jetzt tut es aber weh.
Und das ist aber dann wieder weggegangen.
Und ein anderes Mal war das bei einer längeren Radtour im Sommer, als es heiß war
und wir eine längere Tour gemacht haben und so.
Und mit einmal hatte ich dann auch dieses, aber das ist nicht so heftig gewesen wie jetzt.
Und es ist auch eigentlich, dann so, wenn ich wieder ruhig war, besser geworden.
Aber jetzt kam das wirklich ohne, dass ich sagen kann, ich habe mich jetzt nicht angestrengt.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe so verstanden, Sie haben früher dreimal erlieher Beschwerden gehabt.
Ja.
Aber das ist immer wieder weggegangen.
Okay.
Immer wieder weg.
Und haben Sie höchstens Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen?
Ja, Herzrasen, das habe ich schon das Gefühl, dass das Herz, ja, also auch gerade dann,
wenn das so schmerzhaft ist, dass es dann schneller ist, ja.
Ja, okay.
Und Husten habe ich sowieso immer ein bisschen.
Also ich habe so ein chronischen Husten eigentlich.
Ja, ich rauch halt auch und rauch auch in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen mehr.
Also, ja, Husten habe ich schon immer ein bisschen.
Ja, okay.
Und ist der Husten trocken oder schleimig?
Der ist eher trocken.
Trocken, okay.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen, also Ihren Allgemeinen zustande.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich wüsste nicht.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig, nee.
Ja, okay.
Ist bei Ihnen Stufros oder Nachtschweiß bekannt?
Nachtschweiß? Nein, also, Nachtschweiß.
Also jetzt über Tag habe ich mit einmal so geschwitzt,
aber normalerweise schwitze ich nachts nicht.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben beim Attacken kalzischweiß.
Vorhin hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich ganz nass geschwitzt war.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlkrank oder beim Wasserlasten?
Na, Gott, das will ich nicht.
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Ich hoffe nicht, nein.
Eigentlich habe ich keine Beschwerden da.
Ja, okay.
Und zu wie ist der Appatit?
Normalerweise ist der gut,
ist das jetzt nicht mein erstes Thema.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie letzte Zeit angewicht zu verloren oder zugenommen?
Haben Sie beim...
Das ist eigentlich immer gleich.
Das schwankt mal so um Kilo hin und her,
aber eigentlich ist mein...
Ich wieg mich jetzt auch nicht ständig.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Also, ja, normalerweise kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen.
Wenn ich so ein bisschen Stress habe,
dann habe ich mal Probleme einzuschlafen,
aber eigentlich kann ich so nochmal schlafen.
Okay.
Einschlafen, Probleme haben Sie.
Ja, aber nur manchmal.
Also nur, wenn es wirklich gerade um Probleme geht, ja.
Ja, okay.
Und leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, dieser komische Husten,
aber das ist auch das Einzige.
Ja.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie total gesund bis auf Hüste?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Ja, und jetzt halt dieses...
Dass ich so Brustschmerzen habe, ne?
Ja, okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert geworden?
Operiert worden?
Ja, das war...
Ja, da habe ich auch beim Fahrradfahren einen Unfall gehabt.
Und da habe ich mir den linken Unterschenkel gebrochen.
Und das haben wir auch schon lange her, es ist schon 15 Jahre her.
15 Jahre.
Und dann musste das operiert werden.
Und das ist halt...
Nachher musste das Metall noch wieder entfernt werden.
Okay.
Und gab es Komplikationen beim Operationen?
Nee, das ist eigentlich ganz problemlos verlaufen.
Gott sei Dank, ja.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Und so, sind bei Ihnen, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie vertrage alles,
aber ich möchte noch mal fragen,
sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Also, so viel ich weiß, habe ich nichts.
Nix.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Medikamente ein oder regelmäßig?
Ja, also ich nehme ACC, wenn der Husten schlimmer wird.
ACC?
Ja.
Und dann nimmt man mal eine Aspirin, wenn man Kopfschmerzen hat,
wenn man ein bisschen viel getrunken hat,
oder ein bisschen wenig Schlaf hatte oder so.
Dann nehme ich schon mal eine Schmerz-Tablette,
aber das kommt nicht oft vor.
In welcher Dusiliegrat ACC nehmen Sie ein?
Oh.
Ja, das sind ja immer so Brausetabletten.
Und die nehme ich, muss ich gerade überlegen,
weiß gar nicht, was da drauf ist.
Ich glaube, das sind das 600 oder 800, ich glaube 600.
Ich weiß es aber nicht genau.
Ich nehme die ja, wie gesagt, nur bei Bedarf,
und dann habe ich die halt immer zu Hause.
Und wenn es dann gerade wieder so ist,
dass der Husten nicht weggehen will, dann nehme ich das.
Okay.
In welcher Dusiliegrat ACC nehmen Sie ein?
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Ja, das sind, glaube ich, 500.
500.
Okay.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Das ist Frau Dr. Schröder.
Schröder, danke schon.
Und wir kommen jetzt zu Ihren Familienanamnese.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also meine Mutter hat so eine Rheuma-Erkrankung,
die hat Arthritis, die hat also mit den Gelenken große Probleme
und viel Schmerzen.
Und mein Vater, der ist schon sehr früh verstorben.
Der hatte sehr früh einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt.
Es tut mir leid zu hören.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder und eine Schwester.
Bruder, sind beide gesund?
Die sind beide gesund, ja.
Ah, Gott sei Dank.
Und wir kommen jetzt zu Ihren Lebensgewundheiten.
Lebensgewundheiten darf ich wissen, ob sie rauchen?
Ja, und zurzeit rauche ich auch mehr als früher.
Ich habe eigentlich viele Jahre lang nur so zehn Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Aber ja, seit meiner Scheidung habe ich ein bisschen mehr Stress.
Und da habe ich, also jetzt rauche ich fast jeden Tag ein Päckchen,
muss ich sagen.
Nach der Scheidung, wo viele Zigarette rauchen Sie jeden Tag?
Jetzt rauche ich jeden Tag eine Packung.
Wobei heute habe ich nur morgens früh eine Zigarette geraucht,
aber noch ehrlich mehr.
Okay.
Und seit wann rauchen Sie Zigarette total?
Seit, seit ich 19 bin, so 23 Jahre, ne?
19.
Also seit dem 19. Lebensjahr, hm?
Ja, im Alter von 19 meinungsjahr.
Ja, genau.
Sind Sie trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also gelegenlich trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein.
Am Wochenende trinke ich mal so drei, vier Flaschen Bier,
aber sonst eigentlich nicht viel Alkohol.
Okay, täglich nehmen Sie reingelassig Wein zu Sie?
Nein.
Also Wein eigentlich eher selten.
Am Wochenende ziemlich regelmäßig ein paar Flaschen Bier.
Ach, morgens.
Und Wein halt bei Gelegenheiten, wenn man schön essen geht,
oder wenn man Freunde trifft, oder wenn es ein Fest gibt.
Bei Mann lassen.
Sind Sie total geimpft?
Total, weiß ich nicht, ob es so irgendwas gibt,
was ich nicht habe.
Aber ja, also ich habe mich seinerzeit gegen Covid impfen lassen.
Als Kind bin ich natürlich auch geimpft worden.
Ja, das hat man ja so gemacht.
Haben Sie Passimpfung dabei?
Den Impfpass.
Oh, der Licht schön zu warm und trocken zu Hause.
An den habe ich jetzt wirklich nicht gedacht.
Ja, okay.
Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, konnte ich mir gar nicht erlauben.
Nein, ich bin dieses Jahr gar nicht weg gewesen.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind geschieden.
Ja.
Und erlebten Sie allein?
Meine Tochter lebt bei mir.
Und Sie haben eine Tochter?
Eine Tochter, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, die ist gesund.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Speditionskaufmann.
Speditionskaufmann.
Ich arbeite hier bei einer großen Spedition.
Und das ist natürlich manchmal stressig, ja.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich fahre schon ziemlich viel mit dem Fahrrad.
Und ja, ich versuche auch, hin und wieder mal
mich zum Tennis zu verabreden.
Aber ganz regelmäßig würde ich das jetzt nicht sagen.
Ja, okay.
Und Sie nur Fahrrad?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und ich möchte Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Zurückkommen.
Und möchte zusammenfassen, wenn ich etwas falsch sage
oder falsch verstehe, sage oder falsch verstehe,
bitte korrigieren Sie.
Und Sie haben seit zwei Stunden
Brustschmerzen.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie
Angst gefühlt und die Schmerzen in der linken Arm
die Schmerzen strahlen in der linken Arm.
Und es ist Ihnen übel,
aber müssen Sie nicht erbrechen.
Sie haben schon ein bisschen Beschwerden.
Früher hat es drei Mal gehabt.
Zwei Mal?
Zwei Mal gehabt.
Entschuldigung.
Aber diese Beschwerden sind früher
von selbst weggegangen.
Genau, ja. Und jetzt muss ich sagen, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen ruhiger, seit Sie den Monitor angeschlossen haben.
Da habe ich das Gefühl, ja, jetzt kann nichts mehr passieren.
Ja, okay. Und Sie
haben auch Herzrasen.
Und Sie haben...
Ja, das war nicht mehr so schlimm, das war halt vorhin vor allen Dingen.
Ja, okay. Sie haben
für diese Beschwerden
irgendwelche Arzt- oder ihren Hausarzt-Besuch.
Ja, ich bin sofort hierher gekommen, ich hatte solche Angst. Also, da bin ich direkt hier in die Klinik gekommen.
Ich habe es schon mal zu Hause gemacht, aber Sie haben schon ähnliche Begegnungen.
Ja, ich habe gedacht, das ist ja wieder weggegangen, das habe ich meinem Arzt gar nicht erzählt.
Ich gehe nicht so oft zum Arzt. Ja, okay. Aber Sie haben...
Ihr Vater
ist an Myokat infrage verstorben.
Und Sie sollten ein bisschen...
Da haben Sie mir keine Angst jetzt. Die haben Gottes Willen.
Ja, aber Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, das haben Sie schon alles so wiedergegeben.
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Na ja, jetzt wie es weitergeht natürlich und ob ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Ja, ja, Sie, wir müssen Sie hier behalten.
Und weil es gefiel,
weil es viele verschiedene Krankheiten gibt,
die ähnliche Bescheid haben
und wir werden genau Diagnose
schütteln,
brauchen wir ein paar Untersuchungen
durchzuführen. Okay, okay.
Ich,
jetzt eine Krankenschwester
kümmert sich um Sie.
Das ist gut, ja. Ich komme gleich.
Ja, das ist gut.
Artif eine Frage stellen. Natürlich.
Sie haben ja gesagt,
es ist normal passiert,
gibt es eine Auslöse, so wie Rennen und Belastung?
Ja, das habe ich auch beschrieben. Ich habe gesagt, einmal bin ich
intensiv in der Hitze Fahrrad gefahren
und einmal bin ich eine Treppe schnell hoch gelaufen. Also immer nach starker Körperlicker anstrengen.
Ein Belastung ist.
Aber jetzt war es eben ohne Belastung.
Ja, sie hat ja eigentlich noch fast angedauert, aber die Schmerzen sind weniger geworden.
Also halbe Stunde oder ja, es kommt ein Jahr lange vor,
wenn man Schmerzen hat, da kann man die Zeit nicht gut einschätzen.
Artif Frage nochmal fragen.
Nehmen Sie Pillen?
Ich bin ein Mann. Ja Mann, ich schuldige.
Ja, Jürgen Winter. Ja, Jürgen.
Gott sei Dank.
Ich sage, ich bin ein Mann.
Ja, das ist immer die Schwierigkeit.
Die Fälle sind, aber in diesem Fall bin ich ein Mann.
Aber Dr. Karatschus hat das schon richtig gesagt mit dem Mann.
Was kam gerade, irgendwas kam gerade noch.
Ach so ein Hydrospreik haben die Frage.
Ich habe gar kein Zuhause.
Malen Sie, ob der Doktor mir jetzt welche Sätze geben soll?
Wir gucken weiter.
Ich könnte nicht gerne aufholen.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob Schmerzintestät würde.
Ich habe Ihre Frage akustisch nicht gut verstanden,
weil das sehr leise war, Herr Doktor Kubil.
Ich habe keine Frage, ob Schmerzintestät gefragt würde.
Hat er nicht gefragt?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
Am Anfang waren sie bei 6 von 10.
Und nachher dann bei 3 von 10.
Ah, ja, okay.
Der Charakter, der Charakter Schmerzen.
Drückend stechend Schmerzcharakter.
Ja, wenn er noch ein Frage ist.
Letzte Frage.
Sie haben gesagt,
sind bei Ihnen Schwellungen an ihren Beinen aufgefallen?
Das ist dem tatsächlich nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, hat er nicht bemerkt.
Er weiß nicht, ob welche sind, aber er gibt keine Angegäste.
Können wir?
Dr. Karakus?
Ja, gut.
Hallo Frau Oderarzin.
Haben Sie seit?
Ja, Sie haben neuen Patienten aufgenommen?
Ja, das haben Sie gesehen.
Es handelt sich um
42-jährige Herrn Jurgen Winter.
Der 1 Meter
82 groß
und 94 schwer.
Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit 2 Schüttern
5-Teehänden,
4-Liege einsetzen
und progredierte Drücken
Retro-Sternale Schmerzen mit Alstrahlen in linken Arm.
Und als Begleitzentrum
Ich drehe Sie nicht vor?
Ja, das folgen wir noch.
Als Begleitzentrum beschied er
Todesangst und nausel ohne Emesis
und Takikardi.
Außerdem gab der Patient
dass er früher
schwer gehabt hatte.
Aber damals sind diese Schmerzen
von selbst weggegangen.
Und der Patient klagte
auch kalterweise beim Ataken.
Während der Atak?
Während der Atak.
Die Schmerz-Strechbedingte
in Somni
und Anvorerkrankungen
sind beim Patienten
keine Bekannt.
Und vor Operationen
beim Patienten wurde
eine Operation
aus der Söntese
wegen unterschenklicher Fragdüü
und unterschenklicher Fragdüü
machte ein Fahrrad und Fall durchgeführt.
Und es gab keine Komplikationen.
Bei den Patienten
sind Allergien
oder Unvertrichlichkeiten auch keine Bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt
Assisi
800 Milligramm
und beim Patient
hat Husten,
und während der Atak
nimmt der Patient Assisi
und auch der Patient
hat manchmal Kopfschmerzen
und bei Bedarf nimmt er
Assi 500 Milligramm ein.
In der Familienanwesen
leidet seine Mutter
an Rheumatoid Arthritis
und der Vater
ist an Myokarte infarzt
sehr sehr früh verstorben.
Er hat zwei Geschwister
einen Bruder und ein Schwester
und die beiden sind gesund.
Und der Patient
hat eine Rauchsigarette
aber normalerweise
bevor der Scheidung
Rauchsigarette ist täglich 10
aber nachdem
der Patient
nimmt
ein oder zwei Glasswein
oder ein oder zwei Flasche Bier
am Ofen der Susi.
Fragen, Drogen
ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Der Patient ist vollständig
nach Auslandreise wurdeverneint
und er ist geschiedet
und lebt mit seiner Tochter
seine Tochter
die gesund ist
und er ist
auf dem Ofen
die Leute mit den großen Autos
die Spediteure
und er
reakt regelmäßig sportfährt
und fährt.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Wir haben die restlichen Angaben
am 1. auf eine akut Corona-Synrome
und differenzial diagnostisch
kommen Pulmener-Emboli
und Artisektion
und Autisektion
Was war das letzte?
Art-Ryktöre
Art-Disektion
und Reflexkrankheit
Ich habe schon
das erste Geschenk unterbrochen
Das ist wichtig, ja, genau
Ich
habe
ich habe
seine Herz und seine Lunge
abgehört und
geschrieben und mit der Parameter kontrolliert
und ich habe schon Blut abgenommen
um Herz-Enzyme
Ich meine damit
Tropfen
und
meine Differenzdiagnose
ist Pulmener-Emboli
Deswegen veranlasse ich
und ich veranlasse
die Echokardiografie
und ich
verderte
die kardiologische Konzilante
Ja, das macht den. Ja, sehr gut.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt
Das sieht ja ganz so aus, dass er tatsächlich
ein Problem hat
Sie nehmen den Patienten dann wahrscheinlich stationär auf, oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Und dann gucken wir den nachher zusammen nochmal an
wenn Sie mit Ihren Untersuchungen fertig sind.
Ja, wir können gleich zur Manöverkritik kommen
Ich fand es war eine sehr gute Anamnese
und es war auch eine sehr gut zusammengefasste Wiedergabe
Es gibt es eigentlich überhaupt keine Beschwerden.
Am Anfang hatte ich ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, sie gut zu verstehen
aber nach einer Weile habe ich mich eingehört.
Es liegt vielleicht auch ein bisschen an der Übertragung
aber ich habe sie nachher sehr gut verstanden und ich muss sagen sprachlich
fand ich sie ausgesprochen gut. Sie haben wenig Fehler gemacht
und jetzt bei der Wiedergabe gab es nur ein paar
Winzigkeiten wirklich. Der hat gesagt, der ist 1,84 groß
und tatsächlich ist er 1,82.
Haben Sie gesagt 1,82? Das war doch das Einzige
dann
ja, was ich mir gewünscht hätte, dass sie diese Geschichte
mit dem Monitoring, dass sie die Befragung unterbrochen haben
das hätte ich dem Oberarzt also gleich gesagt
ja, also nachdem ich berichte über Herrn Winter
der so und so alt, so und so schwer
er hat sich wegen starker Torachschmerzen vorgestellt
vielleicht hätte man da noch diesen Begriff
Retro-Sternal schön bringen können
das ist ja so diese klassische Beschreibung
ich habe den Patienten gleich
mit dem Monitor angeschlossen und habe die Vitalparameter überprüft
habe danach die Befragung fortgesetzt die Folgen des Ergab
und natürlich müsste man in dem Augenblick
schon Befunde liefern und sagen
Blutdruck war bei, Puls war da, Sauerstoffsettingen
war okay, EKG war unauffällig oder auffällig
das würde man natürlich im realen Fall dann ja schon liefern können
aber wir haben halt keinen realen Fall
ich sitze hier ein paar hundert Kilometer weit weg und sie können
mich nicht wirklich untersuchen und ich habe Gott sei Dank auch kein Herz in Fahrt
also wir müssen das ein bisschen
schon mit, aber ich hätte das schon früher gesagt, dass sie den
untersucht haben und auch, was ich gut fand, dass sie gleich Blut abgenommen haben
für das Troponin, das dauert ja immer so ewig lange
und ich habe das nicht für das Troponin bestimmt haben
und insofern finde ich das gut, dass sie das gleich am Anfang abgenommen haben
und nicht erst hinterher, gut
ja, auch so, was ich tatsächlich jetzt nicht gefragt habe
und was sie an Untersuchungen machen würden doch, wir haben gesagt, wir haben die
körperliche Untersuchungen, haben wir so ein bisschen weggelassen
da würde man natürlich noch, habe ich jetzt tatsächlich
gucken, ob der unter Umständen tatsächlich geschwollene Beine hat
ja, aber sie haben ja eigentlich schon gesagt
ich habe den vorher abgeheucht und ja, gut
ja, also das war das Eigen, Einzige mit den
Zahlen oben, dann ja, was mir auch nicht so
gut gefallen hat, dass sie gesagt haben, er hat
progredienten Schmerzen, eigentlich
waren die Schmerzen ja später weniger
ja, er hat, am Anfang waren die ganz doll und nachher
war es weniger, also erst war es 6 von 10
ja, und nachher 3 von 10, also waren sie eigentlich
nicht progredient, so, jetzt muss ich gucken
das habe ich denn hier aufgeschrieben, ich kann das gar nicht mehr lesen
ich glaube das ist etwas anderes, so
dann, ja, beim Alkohol haben sie, ja, Rückläufig, sehr schön
danke, ich sage, man regredient, ich weiß es gar nicht
beim Alkohol waren sie sehr genehmig mit ihm, er hat gesagt, er trinkt 3 bis 4
Flaschen Bier am Wochenende und sie haben nur
1 bis 2 gesagt, glaube in Deutschland kann man immer
eher das Doppelte angiben von dem, was die Leute
nehmen oder rechnen von dem, was die Leute angiben
aber sonst haben sie alles wirklich perfekt wiedergegeben
ja, das würde ich auch noch ein klein bisschen anders vorlesen
es ist wirklich eine sprachliche Spitzwindigkeit
Sie haben gesagt, in der Familie in Anamnese
leidet die Mutter an romatisch, romatoida atritis
ne, also in der Familie in Anamnese
er gab sich oder gab der Patient an
dass die Mutter unter Romatoida atritis leidet
ja, also in der Familie in Anamnese leidet man nicht
ja, sondern in der Familie in Anamnese frage ich danach
und dann kriege ich die Antworten, das ist aber schon wirklich eine sehr spezielle
ja, wie gesagt, Detailgeschichte
in der Formulierung, nur das gilt für alle
das sollten sie nie sagen, in der Familie in Anamnese hat
sondern die Frage nach der Familie in Anamnese er gab
das und das oder zur Familie in Anamnese gab der Patient
an, das und das, oder?
das müssten wir vielleicht nur als, also ja, eine
Winzigkeit, doch, also gehen sie sehr entspannt
in die nächste Woche in ihrer Prüfung, ja, es ist alles gut, würde ich sagen
ja, und ich wünsche ihnen, dass sie
einen netten Fall bekommen und dass sie supernetsche Prüfer kriegen
ja, gut